how low brow is it to have trump as a  hero  like what you know it's this is very  coarse right it's not this is not deep  politics but  the bizarre hair and the strange tan and  the idiocy he doesn't know anything  about history or economics or politics  hasn't read a book in his adult life  he's a billionaire but he can't even  even get suits that look even reasonably  okay  like he's just an embarrassing mess of a  person  and you really have to understand cults  to understand what's going on it's  it's the jim jones stuff i go back to  the people's temple  um uh road to jonestown check out jeff  guin's book it's a fantastic it's  instructive history really  about how these cult leader types end up  with the followers that they have so  dhs is worried  we've been worried and let's hope that  nothing like this happens this weekend